okay in this lesson we're going to dive
into slope and understanding slope as it
applies to questions on the s80 so this
is definitely important concept to
understand let's talk about it so first
of all hope refers to the rate of change
so rate of change is like you know how
fast is something you know increasing or
how fast is something decreasing it's
how it's changing right it's the rate or
the slope and then there's a formula
that you want to memorize for
calculating the slope and that's y 2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 and all this
means is you're subtracting the y
coordinates and then you're subtracting
the x coordinates make sure you put the
wise in the numerator this is also
sometimes referred to as the rise which
is up or down over the run which is the
horizontal direction left to right so
that's the slope it's that rise over run
so let's go through some examples here
so you get some experiences for practice
so the first example it says its lines L
and M are parallel what is the value of
x so you can see here's your two lines
LM what would be the value of acts so
that these two lines are parallel so go
ahead and pause the video so you can do
this on your own and we'll go through it
together so the first thing that you
want to realize is that if these are
parallel it means that they're going
down at the same angle of the same rate
which means they have the same slope so
here you can see this is going down
three and over six so it's a rise of
negative 3 a run of positive 6 that
means it has a slope of negative
one-half so we want this line over here
to also have a slope of negative
one-half so we're going down to and
write X basically right so it's like
negative 2 over X so you can see here
that in order to have a slope of
negative one-half X sure has to be what
X has to be four because you can see
this is going to be negative 2 over 4
which is negative one-half so this x
value right here it's actually going to
be because you're going to the left it's
going to be negative for now you can
check your work if you use the slope
formula say 0 minus negative 2 over
negative 4 minus zero and that's going
to be 2 over negative 4 which
negative one-half so now you can see
they have the same slope and the answer
here is going to be x equals negative 4
okay so let's go to example number two
it says line m in the XY plane contains
points from each of quadrants 1 3 & 4
but no points for quadrant 2 which is
true is the slope of the line undefined
is the slope of the line 0 is it
positive or is it negative okay so the
best thing to do in a problem like this
is just a draw a diagram or now remember
your quadrant school like this 1 2 3 4
see it goes like counterclockwise like
that but you can see it has points in
quadrants one has points in quadrants
three and has points in quadrants 4 so
you can see there's your line like that
right now notice it's going up to the
raid okay your lines going up to the
right so that means it has a positive
slope so the best answer here would be
letter C okay pops of slope okay let's
go to example 3 it says which graph is
parallel to 5x minus 10y equals 8 well
what you can do to find the slope is you
can rearrange its equation into the y
equals MX plus B form of the line you
want to solve for y and then you can see
the number that's just in front of the x
that's going to be the slope or the
angle of the line so if we do that we
get negative 10y subtract the 5x that's
negative 5x plus 8 divided everything by
negative 10 and that's going to give you
y equals one-half X minus 4 5th but you
can see the number here in front of the
ex that's your slope one-half we have to
figure out which one of these lines also
has a slope of one half so that we know
that they're parallel me and they're
going up at the same rate so let's
quickly see if we can rearrange you so
i'm going to subtract 2x that's for y
equal to negative 2x plus 6 divided
everything by 4 so y equals negative
one-half X plus 3 halves that's a
negative one-half that's the positive
one half now one doesn't work a is out
we do be same thing we get 2y equals
negative 4x plus 10 divided everything
by 2 you can see that y equals negative
2x plus 5 this has a slope of negative 2
these would actually be perpendicular
meaning a formal right angle because the
slope
so our opposite signs and the
reciprocals of one another so sometimes
I ask you a question about lines being
perpendicular opposite reciprocal slopes
but here we're looking for parallel
we're looking for the same slope so b is
out if we go to see we've got 6 y equals
3x plus 9 divided everything by six
because we're trying to get that Y by
itself we get one half x plus 3 halves
there's one half one half so we can see
these are parallel letter schemes can be
your best answer there okay then the
last example example for this one is
just kind of give you an overview of a
type of problems you can see on the SATA
and basically what it is I kind of
modeled like the corn height like the
height of corn and then like tears so
many week okay so basically the question
they would ask you is like between which
two weeks is the growth of the corn the
greatest okay so they're trying to say
you know where the rate of increase of
the corn is the greatest so what they're
really referring to is the slope and so
if you look at these lines you say well
here's the slope here is the slope
here's the smoke appears in smoke so
here it looks like the corn is kind of
growing and it kind of made me starts to
wilt and me to get a little bit shorter
here but where is the rate of change the
greatest that's going to be right here
you can see it's the steepest between
weeks two and three that's going to be
the correct solution for this particular
problems I just wanted to give you a
heads up on how these ones work to give
you a graph you're looking at the rate
of change of the slope that's going to
be when it's changing the quickest okay
now it could also be like a negative
slope and if that was closer to the
vertical the closer to the vertical it
is the greater the rate of change it's
just that this is going to be decreasing
whereas this one is increasing so
understanding slope is an important
concept to really master and understand
for the s80 go ahead and review this
lesson if you need to otherwise i'll see
you in the next lesson